[Applause]
[Music]
oh
quick moment of silence at the top of
the show not from the irish oh
spicy coin the americans threw off the
yoke of the monarchy hundreds of years
ago
boston and ireland i got thoughts we got
we got a lot of uh uk watchers there
uh racked with uh sadness and tears uh
probably catching our show uh so throw
it out in the chat if you're uh watching
from the uk or ireland and are dancing
uh a really fun jig in the streets uh
boating horses in the chat this is this
is not a geopolitical show this is a
nerdy news show
coming at you live from the new rock
stars actual break room here at our
headquarters in los angeles i wish it
was somewhere else today it's a little
hot it's a little hot but here in the
headquarters here in los angeles
uh but we're gonna do our best to
maintain a high
energy level and threshold for quality
content yeah we're gonna do folks we're
keeping the grid intact here that's
right it might be it might be 87 and
steamy but we're going to be performing
like it's 71 and steamy steamy
71 and meaty um coming up on today's
show we've got a lot of fun stuff to
talk about mephisto confirmed
disney plus giving us blue balls yeah
dog confirm
uh we're taking a rear view of the mcu
oh so checking out mcu cabooses
confirmed we've been talking about this
for what is probably i've been
developing this for months okay yeah we
have one of the best uh mandatory funds
i think you're gonna see anywhere
anytime and finally
it's morbid time oh
confirmed
yesterday this video is clickbait with
me uh with me here today does he know
brandon barry
what's he cooking
secret plan koi god
[Applause]
okay
uh we're living the meme over here the
meme and the dream uh thank you to
everybody in the chat we appreciate you
uh watching along with us reacting to us
we'll be throwing up some fun polls
during the show and if you happen to
throw us a couple of doubloons a few
buckaroos in super chats we have a fun
redemption
a one chip challenge now we've done
spicy stuff on this show before but
never at the level of this
um whoever does this will not only have
a bad experience but probably a bad week
zack skin couldn't even handle silly
strings well that's the other thing who
knows what is inside silly string the
silly string is still on the wheel okay
i literally had an allergic reaction
right after my body turned bright red
after tommy uh nonchalantly uh strung me
uh it's still on there i just want for
like scientific research purposes if
it's zack or if it's the string if it's
the string we need to put it to bed
today
okay so i guess i've got to take it
again
for science uh that's right for science
uh there's also some other there are
several don't worry darling squares
available on the wheel we might shake it
up explain queen's opinion we get to
talk about don't worry oh it's just a
conversation piece yeah exactly he gets
to talk about about don't worry baby
which is the movie he thinks he's good
don't worry it was going to be my uh
transmorphers knockoff of don't worry
darling
i didn't feel this comes don't worry
babe right that's right uh but first
before we get into anything else we
gotta do the headlines the headlines
uh some fun ones today oh we got a
trailer for a night uh glass onion
knives out mystery
the upcoming uh sequel to knives out
starring daniel craig and like every
other person you'd like to see in a
movie uh we got some kate hudson's and
dave bautista leslie odom jr catherine
hahn couple members of the mcu i like
how they were like this movie is a
puzzle thing but there's also murder
don't worry there's a murderer
a fun puzzle box dave bautista in a uh
skimpy bathing suit it's got a lot going
for it we're very how does he fit his
gun in there
wow
wow
wow where does this drax time
i think it's just stuck in the waistband
you think it's a side piece it's hanging
out oh a side piece uh that movie again
is coming out on netflix on december
23rd
we've been talking about it limited
theatrical release if you want to see it
on a big screen which might be nice to
your nearest major city yeah well
theater theater chains are pissed they
want it baby because knives that was a
big hit yeah a lot of us went with our
families during the holiday season
because we're like this is a movie you
can go see with your parents and you all
have a great time and we did yes great
time also i mean if hopefully december's
a lot better than september
dry
dry at the moment thanks man not a lot
to go watch so let's go pick up maverick
for the food yeah i'm gonna see it again
i'm gonna see spider-man and top gun
again
we do get some folks coming in in the
super chat from europe not necessarily
oh oh no that's a yeah
and grim scotland never love all you
guys that is within the commonwealth
that's where she died she died
so um thank you andrew mckee mckee that
is a scottish name sir thank you andrew
mckee uh thank you very much okay other
headlines uh the boys creator eric
kripke uh told toxic fans to stop
watching the show on twitter i'm gonna
quote him directly here he said eat a
bag of dicks and [ __ ] off to the sun
which is just oh sweet this one's like
you want your manager going to bat for
you again customers you know what i mean
yes i think that's what eric said to me
last time he was in l.a uh eric boss um
it's also it's like bro i got bezos
money yeah you think i need a couple
goons on twitter to be watching my show
i don't care about you guys get out of
here if you're going to be nasty well
they were they'd been harassing
starlight yeah aaron moriarty had come
out and like had uh
spoken to variety and i think put some
stuff on her own instagram saying like
she's had a pretty rough experience with
people treating her not so nice on
online uh not the you know there's been
a rash of especially female uh actors
who have not been treated well
because i feel like women are always
treated so well everywhere they go
especially online i like that eric
kripke's getting ahead of it because of
that exact thing like i love that this
is authentic to the show i love that it
shows who he is as a person why we've
earned this show and it's also like
being like
if you're watching the show for the
wrong reasons then get out uh if you're
liking certain things on the show you
didn't realize who homelander was
playing the fight club effect where all
the insults yeah you're that's my guy if
you're taking the wrong message from
this show i love jordan belfort this
guy's my hero yeah right and andy's like
he's speaking from the safety of having
multiple seasons in the bank and
probably multiple systems
yeah two spin-offs one animated one
the hottest show runner uh in hollywood
after that show ends absolutely and good
for good for him for using it's a good
challenge i also think we need more of
that because we do have so much
negativity and toxicity in fandom like i
wish more creators had the clout built
on the like shows he's done to be like
because it's gotten worse and worse
during uh kenobi right when it's like
you and mcgregor goes online he's like
hey you guys you're not real star wars
blah blah let's see a little more like
hey [ __ ] off yeah get the [ __ ] out of
here i would love that yeah yeah uh some
teeth uh which i've i've always said
that about film juice in our comments
coming back
stop cutting promos
uh oh uh happy disney plus day everybody
hey celebrating did you celebrate with
mountains of new content and trailers
what's that what would you wear or green
underpants green under plants for disney
place day yeah okay you won't get
pinched that's right um i sacrificed a
goat at the altar of capitalism oh okay
well we're we're cracking jokes because
not a lot happened today on disney plus
day uh we did get a rogue one uh promo
like a nine minute promo that they had
shown in theaters with the re-release of
uh rogue one for i'm sorry i said rogue
one but i meant andor yeah where we got
an andor promo um but not a lot else
they're clearly saving all their big
guns
for saturday okay saturday is d23 we
know that feigster is gonna be on stage
uh coy had some intel about limited time
well i think kevin feige is going to be
doing exactly what he needs to do to
prove that this is their home base like
i think he's going to come out and be
like d23 you thought you know comic-con
was big by the way this is it so i think
there's a big tell in them not using
disney plus day like to me this being so
quiet is like hey we gave you guys a
comic con you didn't expect hey we know
you love us and then i think friday and
saturday are gonna be insane huge can i
oh go ahead well that one panel right
it's like lucasfilm marvel and twenty
did you see they added 15 minutes to it
they added another figure it's now 3 30
to 5 15 which that was funny they're
like we've looked it over perhaps too
bold for two hours like it's it's
rounding up slowly so i'm excited i just
wonder if like feige will be there the
whole time and while the other studios
get to present he gets to just stand in
the back and go
all right interesting i like to think
he's already called dan lynn like all
right
oh you're gonna go with that okay okay
that's it huh yeah but we are
anticipating and we even got
confirmation the hollywood reporter did
confirm there's going to be some big
marvel news on saturday right there's an
article about like how hard it is for
marvel to avoid leaks with uh from
within the studio but then it had a
little sentence in there they said
exclusive footage they said casting
announcements sort of what we all
expected who knows if we'll get to see
the footage but you know for one like
even though we're in this space i
personally would rather get locked down
like it was phase one like i i'm not
loving the fact that we're hearing so
much by way of leaks like i don't think
it's good for the films i don't think
it's good for phone culture i don't
think it's good for our work if we find
like the first image of a costume i
don't want to see from a paparazzi then
i
expect something and then like when they
put the polish on i'd rather see it
right and i'd rather not hear a leaked
five casting announcements and then
wonder how the other four would have
played them i'd rather experience like
what they intended so i think they
should lock down i think we should like
get it from the proper source because
leaks are not it doesn't benefit anybody
except for tmz and vultures of pop
culture right someone's got to stop
these funko pops yeah they're the real
problems
i'm learning too much from funko pops
yes
get your toy house in order disney um
yeah so we're we're anticipating some
really cool stuff we are going to be
covering it both in person we'll have
some folks down there in anaheim um mr
barrack is gonna be i'll be there in the
hall
along with what'd you say whoa
yes whoa
well he said no
i didn't want brandon to leave the
county uh also
with brandon we're gonna have t michael
bechtel tommy's gonna be down there with
him also with them boss boss eric voss
is going to be down there with them
corey's going to be there there doing
his name very excited um and then here
in our um sauna like studio
myself john erica
tom michaelson i'll be here maybe some
special other folks we're going to have
a whole crew here reporting as the news
breaks playing any trailers that come
out showing you supposedly we're going
to get a new kind of forever posters
going to be released on this poster
maybe there'll be some little easter
eggs yeah yeah it said it was going to
be like a conceptual poster so i don't
know what that means but i'm excited
magic eyes i hope it's like a picture's
cut out of magazines
they draw on like the black panthers
was like oh it looks like mike peter to
me um and so we're gonna be reporting
back and then once tommy and brandon and
eric are done watching the panel they're
gonna like call in from the show it's
gonna be like our comic-con coverage but
even better so check this channel on
saturday saturday morning pacific maybe
afternoon if you're on east coast in the
middle of the night if you are
in poland um so but watch out watch out
for that check out our social medias
we'll be updating uh but back back to
headlines another star wars news
deadline is reporting that the acolyte
has added squid game star lee jung-jae
to its cast apologies i'm sure i
butchered his last name there uh and
that was the main star there he is of
squid game um details about his
character being kept under wraps however
deadline is referring to matt as the
male lead
huh cycle is going to be a pretty
significant role or there's seven female
leads ahead of him well this show
it is like a female-like show so yeah
there might that might actually be true
where there are seven uh female leads
that's true but the the article said
like uh alongside so and so who was the
who was the other lead so i don't
know who knows who knows who knows um
concept artist phil saunders showed off
some cool new stark tech that was
originally conceived for avengers
infinity war in the art do we have
images for this yeah so yeah uh oh there
it is
in the art rhodey fights proxima
midnight and corvus glaive remotely
kind of how like uh everett ross uh
fought remotely uh i probably did that
with condonship and black panther right
kind of
vr style um
looks cool as hell hey can we get this
in armor awards yeah i was going to say
that seems like maybe because you you
find that they use concept art and then
you see it like four years later in
another movie it's like we had this cool
idea so tony introduced that in like
iron man 3 right where he's like remote
piloting and then in spiderman they
brought it back yeah yeah all right yeah
would not surprise me and also we need
more roadies so it wouldn't surprise me
if they they implement that today also
how funny they just like put that out
like hey this movie came out uh
that on the instagram post he was like
yeah he's just going through some little
concerts
i don't understand like what rights
these concept artists have for their art
they're like
contracted out by marvel and then like
after the film comes out they're like i
don't know check it out
marvel doesn't care they're like oh yeah
we wanted you to not show
you know tony stark with the uh cloak of
levitation we would prefer if you had
not done that it's also great all these
artist pages are always like so over the
top with their like presentation they
have like slideshows yeah weird
galleries you have to go through and
it's always like i just show him the
pictures
with all the pictures all right he took
time there oh you can't put that
toothpaste back in there we're three
dollars away three dollars a day away
from a redemption where one of us could
die just kidding we've
oh we got some iron heart casting news
uh wish that sure is already filming yes
yeah it's still casting that's okay uh
or maybe maybe the news is just getting
kind of wrapped i don't know yes uh but
uh they just added actress shakira
barrera to the cast who i personally
knew from um she was on a big story arc
in glo
the allison brie uh wrestling show uh
she's worked a ton we don't know what
role she's playing but good for her
maybe the wakanda forever
isn't a post-credits scene for doctor
doom like we all theorize what if it's
an iron heart and that's why they added
a cast member oh that could be because
we know she's in the movie so maybe
maybe there's a court and how he's
referencing yesterday on the show we
talked about uh reshoots for wakanda
forever taking place this week in
atlanta a lot of speculation maybe it's
a post-credit scene they tend to shoot
those way after a film is done uh yeah
that'd be cool and maybe she's in that
and that's why but something like maybe
maybe that ties in because it'd also be
good for audiences to start tying the
shows to the movies that way like if
you're in a theater i think it's smart
to start doing post-credit it seems to
be like come over to disney plus for
this long-form version yes have they
done that yet i don't think so oh
wow right like not not directly to my
knowledge cause shanxi was a movie one
and black widow was tying in to the next
yeah i think it's all been movie to
movies so far and suppose black black
widow does tie to hawkeye the greater
right right and then this marvel ties to
the marvels so we've gone the other
direction and we know that shangji was
done
they used abomination because right of
shiho
and the plans for that yeah but yeah we
have hit a redemption
threshold so we will be spinning the
wheel
i'll i'll spin that wheel you know i'm
not afraid i was physically harmed the
last time i spun the wheel how dare you
10
john my man
john's place is in the booth we've
always said it we've always known it we
want to shout out a couple of the super
chatters that helped make this awful
moment possible
boogie's world thank you graveyard our
friend uh graveyard depraved gourd uh
thank you let's go for the one chip
challenge or more silly string for zaddy
shame on you graveyard
give me like a half body rash i will uh
spin the wheel here
okay
thank you to good chris chris pine the
best chris
chris bringing us good luck from the
redemption wheel let's go
is going to assemble the mystery shot i
can only assume it'll contain arsenic or
uh my container is leaking that is not
the oh no the teleprompter is going wild
but look uh we're all drinking out of
unorthodox objects here today because
again mugs have been banned from the
break room but more on that later
we've got some news
first things first uh
the new episode of she-hulk came out can
we get the can we get the scores for the
predictions up
oh look at that what it is
we did some tabulating because there's
been talk about some you know
scores so i went back through i looked
at all the scores were disgustingly that
is incredible and it is frightening and
tommy's not up there jessica's not up
there there's people who are on the show
it is it is wild i think the top score
right now is 26 and we've got like four
four or five people with the twenty yeah
well you brought three mystery shots
brandon you can you can pick your poison
and that's with me lobbying between
savage salty and extra are those
accurate descriptions of the mystery
shots i don't know also i mean am i just
picking my favorite um
uh golden girl no no uh rue mcclanahan
i'm i'm disgraced we only had three
one's looking it's either pickle juice
or serge cola okay okay either way it's
a little scary this is clear so it could
be could be water could be vodka it
could be cleaning fluid could be
cleaning fluid and this is some type of
milk uh probably i'm gonna guess since
it came from the break room that is
non-dairy creamer could it be man's milk
you were only gone so long
yeah
these are pre-made they're chilled you
know what in our in honor of uh
graveyard and other people that wish me
harm i'm gonna take two of these oh wow
cause i'm bad at decision making
let's go savage okay bougie badass or
whatever how's that making the stallion
song go this doesn't smell good
is that eggnog
i think it was a pumpkin spice creamer
you think
let me get confirmation on this as i put
it into my body the whole the whole here
take this middle it's a little rare
okay oh
middle one okay i got it it's completely
clear it's got b arthur on it my girl
okay that's a la croix or something yeah
that was a nice bubbly okay a little bit
of the bubbles for you two for the price
of one now let's see if his skin changes
color folks
stay tuned
it's more fake dairy than one person
considering
full
people put like four times that amount
in their coffee i think you'll be okay
uh quick shout out as john gets set up
here fray girl thank you hi brando hi my
boy koi uh komodo crew hi costa the
guido whoa
where would you all take she-hulk on a
date oh free girl that's really good
that's a good prompt where would you
take jennifer walters aka she-hulk on a
date
you want to go somewhere private no no
and she's saying she-hulk should we
assume yeah
because you don't want all everything
yeah you don't want like those poor
[ __ ] bugging for uh attention and
stuff like that i think like a beach
would be fun just because you could do
the whole like carry them in your arms
and jump really far like you can jump
down the beach you know what i mean
really go go for a little fly a rooney
yes i think that would be fun yeah
that's a good one anybody else have any
good plants i want to go to like
somewhere uh like to to learn like i
feel like she's like well read like she
seems to really enjoy learning maybe
like a museum before like whoa oh i love
museums
you know what internet museum dates are
adorable and you learn something that's
for like year two when you're like all
right i guess we're going to go like
the getty would be nice you're playing
the long con at that point right that's
not i would rest in my dates i want to
say just based on the the stinger from
episode three
i want to go dancing with she okay yeah
plus like you know dark night club there
might be some other interesting
characters there she's not she might not
stand out as much plus like the way she
was getting down and twerking right
she's not just physically imposing at
that point yeah i like that you got to
think she doesn't want to be out in
public very much she's getting
recognized by paparazzi here in l.a so
you probably want to do i don't know
cook at home
right now what's happening
i'll put a steak in the oven is this
like beetlejuice where if we say guido
too many times
you transform the sum of the side of him
what has happened
oh shut up episode four
speaking of uh she-hulk jessica's
breakdown is oh yeah
definitely watch that whenever you're
done watching this
yeah i was getting to it okay let's get
into it okay looks like she shut down
for a second
uh hey she hooked episode four dropped
last night jessica we
everyone's wondering why she's not here
we gave her a little break she's been
working a little tushy don't tell her
they don't even work with her
breakdowns she'll be back next week yes
um but if you miss jessica go watch her
breakdown it's incredible mephisto is
confirmed
what's a show
but uh there's other videos on the
channel that are talking about mephisto
we wanted to talk about something that's
a little weirder which is
um
uh one of the people who had gotten
screeners for she-hulk um was combing
through the credits and they noticed
that there was a credit discrepancy
between what was on uh the screener
credit and what ended up on disney plus
if you were uh look watching the
screeners apparently it says uh it
credits todd the guy on the date that
calls her a specimen that guy the
creeper the creepy guy
it credits him as todd
todd hulk
todd hulk
so that kind of got us thinking
who the hell is donald
right and and what does this character
you know what is this character gonna be
doing going forward and just for a
reminder at the premiere
uh uh john bass who plays todd right
said this about his character he said
todd is a billionaire playboy
philanthropist douchebag who wants more
than anything to feel like tony stark
but comes off as john bass um he is used
to getting whatever he wants but he's a
total creep who starts popping up
everywhere so there's definitely more of
of uh todd on the way
and this sort of like
comparison to uh tony stark meeting this
like weird todd hulk
uh description in the credits had us
kind of thinking around the office like
okay what is this character's role gonna
be going forward and like as the season
of of shield is kind of progressing
we're still left with like questions of
who is the villain
of this show it's it's been donnie blaze
one day it's been misogyny another day
it's been titania titania you know
probably emil at some point although you
know i'm on team he's reformed um but i
was doing some digging
doing a little bit of research i want to
kind of bounce this off with you guys um
there's a billion hulks in the comments
right literally a billion and so he
they typically base you know these
characters off of someone from the
comics so i was just sort of trying to
figure out who the heck he could be and
one of the things that i really liked
was this uh the
uh ultimate universe hulk uh which is a
is a bruce banner hulk but he
was like invited by nick fury to do some
research on the super soldier serum
project and in that universe like nick
fury is the one with the super soldier
serum
and uh he was doing some like
self-testing of the super soldier serum
similar to sort of like hulk's mcu
origins right and uh bruce banner
injected himself with this like beta
super soldier serum that turned him into
the hulk right and then years down the
line
super soldier serum has been perfected
and uh what bruce decides to do
is take a little bit of hulk serum and a
little bit of super soldier serum and
put him in a little vial and shake him
up and then inject himself with that
combination of fluids sort of similar to
abomination in the mcu um
uh it turns him into this like insane
psychopath he becomes a cannibal uh it's
super fun it's super cool and like that
idea of taking maybe jennifer's blood
right a little bit of like this hulk
serum and if he has ties to someone like
you know um sharon carter the uh the
power broker who has access to super
soldier serum probably has some reserve
that may be destroyed
he could be going for the blood
he's employing the wrecking crew
well he said he said he was weird right
didn't he say something about her skin
during the day yeah
yeah it's impenetrable yeah which how
would that is that necessarily a known
thing in the public at this point well i
think they
hulk i think most of hulk's shots are
pretty well known sure but it wouldn't
make sense that he just found out that
it's officially and it's obvious with
the wrecking crew and the bent needle
like someone was going someone's going
for it for the blood from the episode
put that together
i love it he's a creep i love it and we
have this blood thing from episode one
yeah hulk was like we have to destroy
the blood if it gets in the wrong hands
it's going to be a problem
you have to know that's going to happen
in the show john bass doesn't seem like
the kind of person who would end up
being the main villain of a show like
this but all the pieces are sort of sort
of yeah and it's a nice sneaky way to
lay the groundwork also to not even
introduce them to episode four
absolutely in a small part sandwiched in
between like three other dates right
like uh that'd be really cool we were
saying i was saying to brandon before we
started filming like also
i don't know he was kind of that actor
was really good in that scene like he
was you know he's coming
one of the best actors of on the dates
i'm like oh wow this guy kind of jumps
off the screen that would make sense
maybe he's destined for more stuff on
the show right yeah yeah so you know i
think
what we're gonna see is
there's gonna be like a lineage to these
criminals right the wrecking crew is
gonna lead to john bass's todd hulk
which maybe is gonna lead to
val and the thunderbolts or or sharon
carter or something right it feels like
they can't have all these disparate
pieces they have to have some kind of
connective tissue so what makes more
sense than him hiring the wrecking crew
ring crew seemed like a bunch of
freaking goon idiots right with and
showed level one henchmen right but so
did todd he was like i don't know you're
a specimen like i'm so interested in
you know like your anatomy it was so
[ __ ] weird um so that is sort of like
what i want to talk to you guys about
long preamble yeah well also interesting
right
if todd hulk is the credit which is
fascinating but also how does this
episode end she's being sued for
copyright infringement because titania
already has the copyright on she-hulk
right so there's a lot of like blank
hulk action going on out there you could
see like maybe in a different version of
this episode that could have been maybe
an overarching theme or something or a
with the show it could have been like a
weird because usually when they do that
double credit thing it's because they're
not recognizable as the other
actors not recognizable i wonder if it
was a weird like
ally mcbeal style vision she had of like
oh this guy thinks he's a hug and she
in her mind imagines it imagines him as
a hulk or something like that
and that got cut and they didn't have
time to come back brandon brandon just
took all the air out of your theory
out the window no no i'm saying like in
that theory he is not playing a larger
part yeah and that theory it was just
like a vision yeah yeah and they cut
that joke because we know they've like
re-edited this
we moved around the parts of the show
late in the in the post-production
process but i will say john bass saying
like he starts popping up everywhere
that seems to be he's coming back right
right right and i'll say this too right
like thunderbolts is right on the
horizon unfortunately william hurt who
plays thadius ross passed away earlier
this year um
she-hulk did shoot before he passed away
so there's a chance but he had been he'd
have an illness so he might not have
been there's a chance he could appear in
the show but i would also say like
there's a good chance they might have
changed if he if he did shoot scenes for
the show they might have done some
reshoots to take that out um but uh red
hook is a big part of thunderbolt so we
we could use a hulk type figure could be
abomination but it could be a new
character or you know it could be a
situation with the flag smashers where
[ __ ] too john bass's character is
selling enough you know hulk goo to a
bunch of weird people and that one of
those people ends up he could have been
funding the flag smashers for absolutely
no the guys have a ton of money it might
be interesting because with william hurt
you know they had a plan there and it's
like ah that we gotta move past that but
like they could establish todd as like
his son or something like and he
inherits
his dad's work or something like that
you know like they i think they could
find a they could add a son
or a daughter real easy
all the shows have ended setting us up
for either thunderbolts or young
avengers so i feel like this one has to
because we we've always had an ending
that felt really important and if black
panther is the end of phase four
this is the last show in phase four so i
feel like there's got to be something
that really ties into where we land
early phase five and i'll say this right
like thunderbolts ends phase five but
phase five ends
in mid-2024 is that right yeah it's like
only a year and a half yeah real short
fast so so we're not talking about some
planning that's going to happen in five
years right also they must
like thunderbolts is it already under
production or they've they've got to be
starting soon right they're doing
previous for sure yeah for sure i i
imagine we're going to get casting news
for thunderbolts uh on saturday um but i
don't i don't think they're shooting
anything well and i i've pitched this
idea and i pitched it this week on rogue
theory uh tune in on saturday for that
little sneak preview uh i i still think
they're going to change the name of
thunderbolts to like thunderbolt
thunderbolts versus young avengers yes i
think that they're waiting to reveal
that you've mentioned that several times
on this show before don't act like
that's a
breaking news soon
i really go into it on rogue theory okay
i might add all the points so kind of
like your harley quinn and the birds of
prey like they make it so like the word
avengers is that yeah like they wanna
they end up changing the title halfway
through the theatrical round because
mt and i were talking about this theory
a little bit earlier today in the office
uh well the virtual office um and he has
a theory that uh todd is working for
someone else that we have seen before in
the mcu i don't want to spoil his theory
because that's for him to share but
check out that video it's going to be on
the channel on sunday is his theory
someone from phase one yes oh i've got a
theory too
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're overthinking it
is
um that's right that's right
uh
i want to talk to you guys more about
this like idea of who is the villain of
the show right
we're four episodes in each episode
seems to have had a different villain uh
episode one
uh a cicar ship that causes a car
accident episode two abomination and
titani i guess titanium was at the end
of episode one episode four we just had
donnie blaze uh etc etc uh here's the
sort of list of people who've been set
up to be villains so far in this show
abomination maybe this todd guy titania
glk and h could end up being sort of
like obviously a shady you know players
obviously obviously the wrecking crew um
if we're talking about a hulk show
uh that is leading to thunderbolts who
knows if red hulk shows up there's a lot
of options right uh i may have been
forgetting some but i think that's the
list so we did a pull in chat and they
don't seem to think that todd is going
to be red hulk okay 65 to 34 i i don't
disagree
i don't disagree with that take simply
because and i don't if john bass is
watching this i apologize oh i don't
think they're going to cast no they'd
get a name they'd get a bigger name
right but maybe he's a bigger name
better mustache i do think he could be
the the [ __ ] guy in madrapore who's
you know doing all the vials and ends up
getting blown up that could be john b no
we know they're going after chalamet for
red hulk yeah hell yeah
just ready he's got the build for it
he's already a man hulk okay you get a a
more that's a that's a hat on a hulk
right there it's a head on a hook
and a hat get out of here um but
uh we we have all done some kind of
screenwriting in some capacity in our
careers um
i've done screen printing
um nice t-shirt
it's called a slash fake john i thought
i thought it'd be fun if we could just
kind of like write our way to the end of
this show right uh you know is
abomination going to be wrapped up with
a todd or a titania or a glk in h yes
doesn't it feel like of this crew of
potentials yeah the the answer is going
to be like not necessarily all of the
above but a couple of the above yeah
right titania is probably working for
somebody maybe glknh maybe todd maybe
whoever right as is maybe like they loop
in abomination
obviously the wrecking crew is working
for somebody they've they've said the
boss did they give a male pronoun to the
boss
do you know if it's a male or female
boss that they referenced in that scene
like the boss is going to be angry chad
if you know the answer call in call in
the show is live it's fisk right
wilson fisk behind you oh that's another
one that you didn't even put on the list
could be it could be kingpin yeah yeah
yeah so
there's two there's two columns right
there is the
abomination
i'm sorry there's the there's like the
todd wrecking crew column and then
there's the glk h titania column we sort
of feel like
knh probably hired titanic disease
um to test to see if she was actually
the whole yeah yeah something like that
i also like the idea of this show ending
with
uh jennifer walter she-hulk being like
no screw the system and like kind of
siding with like the thunderbolts if she
meets up with val in the end and val is
like you know whatever happens on the
show in some whatever legal manner the
villain gets away and val's like look
you're never going to solve your
problems going the legal route yeah and
my convinces sort of come over it's like
the thunderbolts is like this is how you
get things done don't you also feel like
the entire your premise here john of
like who's the villain we haven't seen a
villain don't you feel like especially
this show
at some point right like in an
anticlimactic fashion she's gonna look
at the camera and be like you thought
this show had a villain
yeah yeah and we're out we're all
protagonists
that would be very fun
uh things to munch on right episode five
next week will will probably help us
sort of i think they're gonna start you
know really focusing the show i think we
get a big arc next starting next yeah we
know we got a full courtroom thing we
know uh jamila jamil has sort of
insinuated that titanium would be a
bigger player in episodes five or six
she said um so she'll start appearing
more she's obviously suing jen so more
pug more puck more punch no plug this up
true villain of the show oh pug could be
in there too i don't think so he seems
like a great guy um real quick uh you
saying something to munch on you know
what we're not munching on oh spicy
chips because we're not hitting any
redemption thresholds right now we are
sitting pretty yet why are you spinning
that john i just thought it'd be fun
gets them going could have gotten a hulk
out you could have cut [ __ ] out but
you didn't but you playing um so hey uh
we appreciate everybody like here for
the cookies
uh who else thought koi was one of the
matcher profiles
i almost sent you a screenshot i i may
or may not have in the trailer when it
came out then like was there a licensing
image over to marvel
jessica
somebody also get she-hulk on raya i
mean she's a celebrity
a lot of love for madison this episode
everyone in the chat's talking about
madison
we got a super chat from uh match 143
saying wong and madison are the best duo
since trevor slattery and morris yeah
who's the who's the morris in that duo i
think
wong's the more yeah whoa
i mean
madison's doing all the heavy lifting in
those scenes she is she's she's
delivering the comedic lines yeah great
great delivery that that actress was
really funny um
uh film juice shame on you coming into
my
chat get out of here film juice get out
of here
um but also um who's threatening you
mike chiro cairo i i don't know how to
pronounce your name mike but uh we
appreciate you let's all at meyer wong's
running jump
entrances one benedict juan was doing
some work man bless his heart that guy's
got a lot of robes he's gotta move
around and he's not a spring chicken
he's a a man of a certain age he's got a
good gig in the mcu the best very
comfortable outfit his face is never
covered he always gets to show the face
yeah they have to have it there
they let him understand she doesn't have
to do gamora level uh makeup gets a lot
of get a lot gets a lot of joke lines
it's a lot of fun hand gestures like he
gets to play it's very playful
yeah he also is not like walking around
in a mocab suit most of the time
benedict want come on the show
bring simu with you yeah pick up seem a
little on the way um okay uh i mentioned
earlier we're all drinking out of
non-traditional
um earlier this week mugs were banned
from the set uh
because
plans were in the works
john at least show them that that's a
that is
not a uh a shell from world war one he's
not gonna make it out of this house
um
so uh
we have uh we're debuting it right now
oh that's right official
new rockstars mug tommy had a design in
the running he's a coward
uh and he's a football fan so he's not
here today he's at sofi stadium probably
uh sweating himself to death watching
his uh bills and rams he's actually it's
probably pregame right now and he's
throwing somebody through it that man
he's going through it with the bill's
mafia but also he's kind of a rough
morning you know yeah everybody loves
tommy but but everybody else
acknowledges he has bad ideas
okay
i i i people don't love me but they do
acknowledge i have good ideas um so
i'm debuting it right now i would say
have we decided that zach's mug wins by
default tommy is not here tommy's not
here so we're not going to see his mug
design
now when we look back on the year 2022
okay my favorite thing we've ever we'll
remember a lot of stuff yeah
we'll remember queen elizabeth queen
elizabeth died betty white almost made
it betty white died william hurt died
we'll remember all those significant
those three people but more importantly
we'll remember the births and the thing
that was burst into the world in 2022
highest grossing movie of all time was
morbius okay and specifically the
maymays that came out of morbius the
more ba made me made um and so to mark
that occasion to mark what was like
one of the best episodes of break room
i present to you the oh it's morbid time
mug okay let me get let me get this on
the good screen oh my god now some of
the screen you can't see so this is a
clock let's see here oh do you have a
better angle maybe maybe this
oh okay look at the top there it's still
terrible it's morbid time beneath that
you see clock hands in the style of the
morbius title
okay beneath that are all of the uh
roman numerals that normally denote the
hours of the day that have fallen to the
ground because you know what you don't
need a clock to know it's more of a time
because the secret is it's always
warming time okay
um the opening credits were the best
part of that movie
come on
this this is now put a little red in
there put a little put a little bit a
little bit you could drink red or blue
you got purple okay it's morbid time no
need to check your watch it's always
morbid whoa
what's going on why did
i heard you on the break room saying
that your mug was the winner no no no my
friend on this show we keep it real and
we keep it gucci to moochie that's why
this
mandatory fun mug is still for sale and
will still be bought by all the little
bechtold maniacs out there because when
it comes to my mugs liquids are best
served
cold
oh my god oh it's so hot phillip
did you put cocoa in this mug
i said burn dairy chocolate milk you put
cocoa in my mug and no marshmallows
i know the economy's rough but no
marshmallows we're aristocrats
buy my mug
buy my mug
please buy my mug
i don't know half of that uh video did
not make much sense to me but
uh okay so this is tommy's mug pitch
here is a mandatory fun mug white on the
outside black and the inside looks like
it's a little bit
i got the right mug i enjoy that film it
is always more than time
my mug smells like the bills here's the
cool thing about these mugs they're
available
right now right now
go to new rockstarsmerch.com you can buy
a mug right now and what we're going to
do is
uh if you buy one of these mugs you're
voting right if you buy the tommy mother
what presented for
school board
from the president
the senate
uh you're voting uh with your purchase
and one of these mugs will become the
official mug of the break room we'll be
taking these mugs into the future
everyone around the table will be having
these mugs one will remain the other
will go so ironically if you buy the mug
that's get gets purchased the least you
will have the most limited edition [ __ ]
so that's a thinker that's a real
prisoner's delay that's right for you i
mean and also you know if you love both
i and tommy even if you just love tommy
you could buy both
um you could you could buy a mistake
here's what i would do buy three right
you could have both of them and then
then you're voting as well yeah i
respect that
where's my mug you didn't you didn't ask
for one oh i didn't realize i had to ask
yeah yeah yeah uh sorry brandon uh but i
mean again it's it's gonna be obvious
you know this is also just rigmarole we
have to go through to fees tommy and
make sure he doesn't get yes you know
butt hurts or whatever but we all know
it's going to be the more than 10 months
one of these has matt smith in it and
i've never seen that on mandatory funds
that's right so that's right you want
your damon targaryen uh representing um
okay they're the two mugs i do love that
the clock is broken because it's always
more of a time
that's a truly inspired decision a lot
of people in the chat seem to be
appreciating the mandatory fun mug
that's fine i mean i get these are bits
that's right olivia and it's morphin
time is loki iconic uh like can you like
having it it's more than time
i mean you guys me and i left it i knew
exactly what i wanted when you're old
and your grandchildren are forced to
clear out your house and they're moving
you in they're gonna google home and
they come across your collection of mugs
and they're like grandma why do you have
so many mugs and they pick up this up
what's it's mobin time and you're like
child you don't understand
before the great flood there were movies
and so on we still have i'm just going
to say that will be studied for
generations to count oh yeah he'll be in
the museum perry clemens travis furman
in the chat yeah i get it you're doing
fun bits like tommy has a good mug i get
it it's like it's like when we call uh
you know uh a short guy tall or whatever
i don't know whatever uh one of those
opposite oxymoron yeah yeah it's
oxymoronic i appreciate it though again
it makes tommy feel good so it's nice um
but moving on um
brandon well you know tommy isn't here
today because he has a crippling
football addiction and he's driven away
from the one thing he supposedly loved
uh but you guys are here and i'm really
excited to say that it is time for
mandatory fun whoa
there's the graphic
that's right
mandatory fun we only play this segment
once here because this is an important
mandatory fund uh i've been working on
this developing this in the lab for some
time okay
uh okay and i just gotta say that this
season that she-hulk has really brought
this mandatory fund to fruition i hope
that wasn't a mug threw my phone on the
ground
but you know especially on like uh uh
she-hulk a lot has been made of captain
america's ass in the emcee we saw it we
saw our phone again this episode
it's a joke
but the mcu is full of butts okay
they're all over it and while we're here
today we're having a little mandatory
fun play the graphic
whoa oh it's late on the draw
while we're here you guys you're experts
at the mcu you've watched all the films
you've seen all the shows
but do you know all the butts at the mcu
this is a mandatory fun i'm so excited
for okay
this is called whose butt is that okay
well you're gonna have to tell me i'm
gonna show you a butt and you gotta tell
me whose butt it is now this could come
from any show or film within the mcu
i've left it all in the mcu okay these
are mcu butts for mcu slash like you
guys so no no uh no
dr michael morbius there will be no
doctor michael morbius but that's saved
for who's who's spider-verse butt is
yeah yeah what's bumpsy butt am i
peeking out so these are mcu butts now
are we gonna see these are gonna be male
1
look at all those peaches in the
children we're talking a little agents
of shields no agents of shield these are
official disney plus shows only okay
okay uh let's throw up that first butt
let's give him this is the dumbest thing
okay
take a look at that
write down your answer don't spoil you
got five seconds who whose butt is this
who's butt oh if you know in the chat
throw them in there throw them in there
there's only one butt that that is okay
let's don't sound so confident
okay okay zach zach has black widow oh
we got three black widows okay now this
is if this is maria hill i'm
before we back out you're all correct
okay but before we back down and show
you if you can tell me
which film this is i will give you extra
points i'll give you an extra point i
mean could this be an iron man 2 an
early careful an early natasha butt uh
jose castillo on the chat saying we all
know whose butt that is yeah it's true
it's true oh it's all right what's up is
that that's an evidence for your answers
it's an avengers
i was gonna say winter soldier yeah i
was gonna say one or soldier two what
about you i said iron man too well you'd
all be wrong it was end game that was a
little tricky that was all from the past
that was an ass from the past please
it was always a heist oh it was never
just a heist i got it backwards okay
let's throw up that second blood thing
for our boys here but two whose butt is
that oh okay these are these
tight shoes
back pocket they know america's no they
know america's ass but they do do they
know everyone yeah you know what that's
probably manchester united oh okay i
think i think it's gonna be
these are like i think
i think um
damn
two seconds no give me again enough time
come on zach come on exact time
zach racking his brain uh
zach wrecking his brain
all right cory what koi what's your
answer
damn it
he's got bruce banner damn it zach's got
bruce i said i said hang people oh i
mean that was my second guess so let's
see the butt oh
professor action
i went for an old man i really get to
see professor x's it's an old man's ass
i mean that is a trick
that's the only time you see that these
are all butts in the mcu let's see the
thing i hate that i remembered saying
that's a flat
whose butt is that what this who's that
you gotta know who this is if you're a
fan who's that butt
show me that butt
got my selection all right let's see
your answers boys we got captain america
one right oh yeah
we're all tied up we're tall we're all
tied up let's see that fourth s come on
let's say that by oh that's daddy juicer
whose butt is that oh it also feels like
a trick
whose butt is that god damn
god i hope it's a man's name i mean i
feel really bad this is i feel like okay
i feel like this is a little bit of a
trick i really don't know good god good
god help from the chat come on they're
they're behind can we see it one more
time is that okay
can we bring up
some people in the chat have some good
ones
they might they might have been guessing
on the last one so can we just oh i see
a lot i see someone i think that's
what's trying to okay he's trying to
okay there you go oh there's the butt
five seconds
come on you know it i saw this in the
chat
oh oh we're stealing answers now i'm
stealing an answer um
seeing some megan the stallion in the
chat
danvers in the chat that's not a butt in
the chat
let's reveal the butt
that was christine palmer 838 oh damn
i love that i always love
i worked really hard to get that butt
shot quality but so nice he crossed the
multiverse twice
what about on christine palmer i should
say we've been planning this segment
since we launched the break room on may
2nd 2022 and just now has brandon had
the time to go frame by i have an
expensive butt file that i've been
developing we will we will play uh whose
butt is that again but we're not done
yet folks let's see the next fight we
have one more what's this score we got
two more
okay well this this whose butt is that
actually this still could be a couple
butts whose butt is that
there's actually even as distinct as
that is i feel like there are a couple
butt options all right let's see your
answers we got ultron abstinence we got
abstinence i'm obsessed oh you're
abstaining and we got ultron
you're abstaining i know the answer to
that oh you're good
let's reveal let's reveal it let's
reveal the bite it's an ultron
so
illuminati
one more this is the final bite okay
let's see the butt
oh i know what this is oh my god damn
it's like gotcha oh this is hard gotcha
i think
ladies and gentlemen this is not fun i
see i see someone saying what i think in
the chat you've already you've already
spun to icarus someone else said icarus
in the church i think that's a great
exactly i said druid
oh i went totally different way ronin or
cacillius wrong
silliest
well that was a great mandatory function
like i said we will play whose butt is
that many more times on the show i have
so many photos and i also realize one of
the photos i have on my files is
inappropriate
due to age
morgan
stark's wasn't sure about one of the
actresses underage it turns out tough
stuff for my guys
these aren't clothed but these are close
we are not we fully own
uh four white guys staring at actors um
i was doing christine palmer a favor by
letting the world know the bundes she's
holding down undead i feel bad because i
thought that was a man's butt and i was
going hard on it being a nice
ryan gosling was willing to throw away
his life for that bud hey and i don't
know i don't disagree i don't blame him
do we have time for some super chats we
were gonna talk about andorra yeah
if you have not watched that nine minute
feature check it out watch it solely for
how peter skarsgard says
he says that the weirdest way you could
choose to say kessie and ender um thank
you to everybody watching i think we
actually have cover covered most of the
super chats travis furman says i demand
tommy's mug and you too can demand
tommy's mug by going to new rocks most
of the chat.com did seem to agree that
glknh is going to be the main uh villain
you know because we can't trust lawyers
oh max savage sent in a chat earlier in
the show possible trailers or at least
discussion of werewolf by night please
you gotta think i thought we were
getting into october like it's gotta be
i mean it's wild that they haven't said
anything maybe they'll just drop
werewolf but maybe
well it does make me think hasn't some
having some people speculated that it's
like it's going to be a short it's going
to be very short it might be a music
video here's what we've heard that we're
not supposed to have heard where will
our mitzvah it's the end of the episode
no one watches this far if you're a
disney lawyer contact brandon don't do
this
do not throw me under the bus
come back tomorrow break room i'll spill
my insiders yeah we don't know anything
jessie waller love from england love
love back to you jesse uh whoa bucky
barnes atl bill's mafia hey bec told
have fun gucci to moochie hell yeah
um
d23 this weekend and you see any of us
say hello uh yeah as as always hit the
like button if you're still watching the
video
and you enjoyed the video
it actually helps a lot yeah
all right check out a mug at new
rockstars.
oh that's coffee too
it is cold nitro cold brew oh
get out of here we gotta get out of here
we'll be back tomorrow goodbye
[Music]